okay we're ready to resume
natalie is everything okay to resume
yeah just
we're back on on youtube now yeah
okay thank you all right well um thanks
for that and thanks for hanging on
um i think the uh the representatives
from the members of the public are
not still with us um but that's okay
i mean it was pretty straightforward
really that um
with with the uh the conditions laid out
by the licensing officer
and the environmental health officer
particularly with the addition of
condition seven under the general
heading that it
um it won't be accessing or egressing
from the old boat yard on edge lane
clearly
um the the residents that attended no
longer had an issue
with and they withdrew their objections
the two other written objections who who
couldn't attend
tonight um were basically the same
concerns really as the one that came
the the two that came to voice their
concerns so
with that we're happy that there's no
objections and we're happy that the
application goes ahead
um so that that is the decision of the
committee that we will will allow the
application to go ahead
okay so thank you very much for
attending everybody
um and mr ross we wish you
all all the best of luck with your uh
with your venture
okay thank you good evening everyone